[ Cheers and applause ]
-Let's do this.
-You're getting woke.
♪♪
-Hey, I'm here with
the one and only Nicki Minaj,
and we are going on
a dinner date to Red Lobster.
-Yeah.
-I'm very excited for this.
I've never, ever been
to Red Lobster ever.
I don't know why.
Our paths never crossed.
You've been there.
You actually --
You worked there at one point?
-I have worked at a couple
different Red Lobsters,
and I've gotten fired from
all three or four of them.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I'm sorry
to bring that up,
but we're gonna have fun
tonight!
-Yay!
♪♪
Oh, hello!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, this is really good.
-All right, one of these.
♪♪
First things first,
we need a drink, right?
-Yes.
-What was your drink --
Well, you didn't drink
while you were on the job,
but what was your favorite drink
that you served?
[ Laughter ]
-I always liked this thing
called Red Passion Colada.
But they don't have
red Alizé anymore.
Therefore, I cannot get it.
The other good thing
is a Lobsterita.
-Lobsteritas?
♪♪
-Here we go, guys.
Lobsteritas, frozen strawberry.
You got it, Nicki?
-Thank you. Yes.
-Awesome.
-Thank you so much!
-Are you joking me?
-I am not joking.
-No, you're absolutely
joking me.
-There you are, Jimmy.
-Oh, my God. Thank you.
-Enjoy.
-It is so good.
You paying?
-I'm definitely getting an Uber.
I know that.
-But are you paying?
-Yeah, of course.
-Okay. Thank you.
-Please, this is --
-I ain't got no money
to spending all this money
at no Red Lobster, child.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Let's act like
we're on a blind date.
-This is great.
-How do you like
your Lobsterita?
-I'm really having a good time
tonight.
-Thanks.
-I like the Lobsterita,
but I like the view even more.
[ Laughter ]
-Of me?
-No, yeah.
We're pretending
we're on a blind date.
-[ Laughs ]
-I haven't dated in a long time.
[ Laughs ]
Can I have more of that?
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I have some biscuits for you.
Enjoy. Those are
our Cheddar Bay Biscuits.
They're delicious.
-Let me talk about this,
because I worked at Red Lobster,
and I know everything
about every food here.
So this is handmade
by a bunch of African people
in the back.
[ Laughter ]
This is a Cheddar Bay Biscuit
toast.
You got to go like this,
1, 2, 3, pssh!
[ Indistinct conversations,
silverware clinking ]
-This is absolutely fantastic.
-Told you!
-Then you can go like this, too.
1, 2, 3, and then in your mouth.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Mmm.
-That's a good biscuit.
-Okay. But my pet peeve is when
people ask for extra biscuits.
Please do not ask
for more biscuits,
'cause I will slap you.
-Can we have more biscuits?
'Cause that is what
I really want.
♪♪
I love it.
D-Lob. That's what I call it.
-D-Lob?
-Yeah.
If you're been here enough,
you call it D-Lob,
and then, dude --
And then S-Fish, live.
They want you to live.
-[ Laughs ]
-So I love it. I get it.
Look at this.
Are you kidding me?
Hey, wait a sec.
A-hole fish?
Oh, a whole fish.
-How are we doing?
Are we ready to order?
-Two ultimate feasts,
and there's other things.
-And I want to add Cajun chicken
pasta to mine.
-Okay. Awesome.
-She's gonna add just some
stuff.
♪♪
-Oh, my God.
This is a lot of food.
-What do we do first?
-I like fried shrimp,
so we can do the toast and dump
it in your tartar sauce
like we did the other thing.
So you go, 1, 2, 3, dip.
-Uh-huh.
-What the hell are you doing?!
[ Laughter ]
-Ooh. [ Coughs ]
You saved my life.
You saved my life today.
♪♪
-Now, I'm gonna show you
how to crack this, okay?
-Yep.
-You just go like this.
Well, let's start with
the legs, maybe.
And you go like this.
And you squeeze...
Oh, God. Um...
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
I can't believe you got fired.
[ Laughter ]
-But see, that's why
I like the ultimate feast,
'cause it's already done
for you.
-Oh, that's right.
You go ultimate feast...
-Yeah.
-...then you can just...
Ah, and splitskis?
-Yes. Sure.
-Come on. Cheers.
-Mmm. So good.
-I mean...
-So good.
Aren't you happy you came here
for the first time in your life?
-Can we have more biscuits?
Ah, man.
♪♪
So, tell me why you got fired
from Red Lobster.
-I walked up to this lady.
Her and her boyfriend
had walked out of the restaurant
and they took my pen
and they didn't tip me.
I walked to the car,
I banged on the car window,
and I said, "Give me my pen!"
-So far, it sounds like
that's not a big deal.
-I started going like this...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, you're number one.
-You're number one.
You're number one, as well.
-And my manager fired me
on the spot.
-Tell the manager, "Hey,
I was trying to get
restaurant property back
'cause they stole your pen."
♪♪
Oh, you know what we should do?
Do you want to do, like,
"Lady and the Tramp"-style?
-No.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Now, I know you got fired
from Red Lobster,
and I think right now it's time
for a little redemption,
a little Red Lobster redemption.
-Okay.
-Upstairs, there's people
waiting for food.
They have no idea
that we're here.
Let's go serve some food
to these great people here.
-Oh, my God. Are you serious?
-Let's get the uniforms.
-Yes.
♪♪
-Oh, my God.
-Is everybody enjoying
their food?
-Yeah.
-This reminds me of when
I was in college
'cause I had muscles
and I also had crabs once.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
-Uh, here we go.
Hi, guys!
-My name is Nicki.
I'm your server for the day.
Nice to meet you.
-Nice to meet you.
-We're from Trinidad.
-Trinidad!
[ All cheering ]
-My country!
My country is in the building!
-I brought you a special drink.
It's a little rum and Coke.
Let me take a taste test
just for a second.
-Whoa. What now?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
I'm so sorry, you guys.
-Can we get one more
rum and Coke, please?
Thank you very much.
-Oh, my God.
Don't eat people's biscuits!
What is wrong with --
I'm so sorry, you guys.
-That's okay. It's okay.
-All yours. All yours.
-So, can I get you guys
anything?
-Are you eating your biscuit
with a fork and knife?
-Yeah, I don't want my hands
to get dirty.
-Get -- Get out of Red Lobster.
-Oh, my God. You cannot do this.
This is too classy
for Red Lobster.
-Get out of Red Lobster.
All right, Nicki,
you've proven yourself.
You redeemed yourself.
We've talked to everyone here
at Red Lobster,
and we have something
special for you --
The first and only black card.
You get free
Cheddar Bay Biscuits for life.
-Oh, my God. This is the nicest
thing anyone's ever given me.
-No, no, no.
-Thank you.
-I also tracked the people down
and I got your pen back.
[ Laughter ]
Redemption.
-You're amazing.
-You've been redeemed.
I love you.
-I love you. Mwah!
Thank you so much!
[ Laughs ]
-Oh, so much!
She's getting choked up!
Oh, my God!
Oh, let's get
the basket of biscuits.
Oh, it's a basket of biscuits.
-What are you guys, insane?
What the hell is this, y'all?
-We love you, Red Lobster.
Let's get in the limo. Let's go.
-Oh, my God.
-Let's go. We gotta go.
We gotta go.
[ Cheers and applause ]